dr. korkor was very clear in saying this
has been the biggest biggest wedge
between the two countries nobody knows
what was said privately between them
Putin is denying it you know the idea
that he has something but here's I think
the most important part that we've got
to get into and that is at some point we
need to have the specific evidence and
the double standard is glaring in this
particular case as it relates to the
servers as it relates to the emails that
are missing and at some point we've got
to say where are where is this evidence
as well because we want to know who knew
what when and where look so let me let
me address the question of how
everybody's reacting to the press or on
the left but first a reminder with
regards to what you mentioned earlier
John Brennan who's accusing the
president being a traitor voted for the
Communist Party at the height of the
Cold War in 1976 when the Soviet Union
actually wanted to destroy America
that's treasonous Vladimir Putin is a
bad guy he's a bad actor but the Russian
Federation is not the Soviet Union and
as far as I know Donald Trump never
voted for the Communist Party at the
height of the Cold War so let's just put
that on the record with regards to the
reactions today summit it's a little bit
like the stroke testimony you saw the
unveiling of the deep state last week
with strokes testimony today you really
saw the depths of the mainstream media
nobody in that room behaved like a
journalist
they were like members of moveon.org or
the other the resistance the idea that
we had a chance to talk about big issues
saving hundreds of thousands of lives in
Syria the question of Ukraine's national
sovereignty and instead they want to
perpetuate this bogus collusion
narrative they came out of the closet
there is no journalism or on the
mainstream media left and it was
absolutely shambolic